now moving on the Pentagon is
considering quadrupling its budget for
European defense in 2017 because of
Russian aggression that's according to
the US defense secretary ash Carter now
i'm joined by a former American
ambassador to NATO robert hunter who's a
senior fellow at the Center for
transatlantic Atlantic relations in
Washington now isn't there a risk that
this move could actually provoke Russia
and make Europe feel more insecure as a
result well I think don't think it's
going to provoke mr. Putin beyond what
he's doing now but it will enable Putin
to go to the Russian people and make the
argument that Russia's being in circle
that Russia's continued to be to be
marginalized in order in part to help
the Russian people be willing to stomach
the the really quite significant
economic impact of what's happening with
the sanctions imposed on Russia plus the
collapse of the price of oil so we know
that this budget is going on what do you
think the money is likely to be spent on
could it be missiles could it be troops
what what you predict well secretary of
state ash Carter's already highlighted
that it's going to be a quadrupling from
about seven hundred and eighty nine
million dollars to about 3.4 billion
dollars beginning in the fiscal year
that starts on on the first of October
he's going to put 250 tanks in the
Central European countries he's going to
continue to rotate american troops in
and out of europe it's going to put more
bases in the East he's going to pre
position equipment to a whole series of
things not so much in my judgment to say
to the Russians we can take you on if
you force it to do it but rather to
reassure the NATO allies in the East
that the United States will stand with
them if push comes to shove is this an
acknowledgment in some ways that the
u.s. hasn't done enough in the face of
Russian aggression in countries like
Ukraine and also in Syria well of course
Ukraine is not a member of NATO and
frankly I think that is where I would
have done things differently from the US
government right now Russia is not going
to be particularly impressed in terms of
what it may decide to do by the
relatively small amount of added
military capacity that's moving into
Central Europe what they would be
impressed by is if indeed there were a
significant amount of money and effort
that would go into Ukraine to bolster
its economy if we would push the
Ukrainians into serious reform and if we
push the Ukrainians into some kind of a
capacity for the Russian speakers in the
Eastern powder country to have more
autonomy I think that's something in the
United States and the Europeans need to
do together that's where I would put the
money if i were really serious about
trying to increase security in europe
this is a nice show piece but i don't
think it's going to make much of a
difference in terms of reality on the
ground in dealing with the Russians so
you're talking about kind of reassurance
if you like how much of a threat is
Russia to Europe well nobody knows
whether mr. Putin having swallowed of
the Crimea and he plus his proxies
having taken a good chunk of
southeastern Ukraine most of whose
people actually are native Russian
speakers but does he intend to go
farther not necessarily in terms of
military action but let's say economic
choke point the price of gas the
availability of a natural gas a cyber
attacks such as we saw in a recent years
in in the Baltic States so what the
United States is doing is saying we will
reassure these countries if there's some
kind of conventional attack but I don't
think this does what is required in
terms of sa deterrence against a
unconventional attack or in bolstering
their economies and particularly the
economy of Ukraine which i think is the
only thing in time which is really going
to impress mr. Putin it's a nice show
but it's not something I think is money
well spent
robert hunter thank you very much for
your time